Robert first question
On Robert Lata BSO when draymond was in here Steph
He said that he felt like a lot of people look at this like a ending
To you guys's run but that would be a mistake on their part. Can you talk about the resiliency of your team?
And if indeed you've you had that feeling as well and should people not put you guys in the grave right now
Tough tough way to go out
You gotta see credit to run on on a great series they
They went out one it they played amazing tonight all across the board. They had contributions and
yeah, it's a tough feeling, you know being on this side of
losing in the finals, but I
Think a lot has been
You know proven about who we are as a team and the fight that we have and
all the adversity that we dealt with, you know this entire playoff run and you know
It's a one-possession game to keep our season alive tonight. So
It would be thinking about this one. It's tough, but
Our DNA and who we are and you know, the character that we that we have on this team. I
Wouldn't bet against us, you know being back on the stage, you know next year and in going forward so
really proud of the way that we fought to the end and this five year runs been been awesome, but
Definitely don't think it's over
Next question right here
I'm Julian Herrera ABC 7 News despite the loss. Can you just talk about all the emotions?
You're feeling that this is the last game at Oracle
I mean for these fans this is this is their Oracle they love this place
and what are you feeling now that this is really over a
lot of different emotions a lot of thoughts
no regrets at all, but
Again what we've been able to accomplish and even how this series ended so we've had a lot of great memories in this building I
Think it's a its iconic in the sense of
our entire history of this organization and and how we got to this point and you
Know whenever I Drive by it. I'll have great memories
Again, what we've been able to accomplish in this building and as we move move across the bridge want to be able to continue that
and create new memories, so
Hopefully, you know every fan that was in this building
Appreciates the journey in the ride every fan that was watching
how Oakland held us down for 47 years and
Turned the page to to you know, bigger and better things, you know coming for this franchise
Fourth row on your right stuff stuff might get a Toronto Sun. Um, you saw a lot of Fred vanvleet in this series
What do you know about him now that you didn't know before?
Me as a gamer
He had some big shots. Not just the
Affairs of pressure he did a lot of daggers that I never seen to, you know
paint it when the ball was and it was it was in his hands and
even tonight he had like three of them that kept a momentum on their side, so
Obviously saw a lot of bodies on defense but uh, you know, he was one that took the challenge and and
Obviously, he's a champion now so well deserved
Stuff
Comparing the the way you lose three years ago in the finals
This is like almost got shut down at a very second very very last second in the game seven to
this finals
You know, there's so many injuries so many people got there. So which one is more painful for you guys? I
Mean losing hurts, no matter what the situation is you
nobody likes that feeling whether it's a game seven or game six or
what-have-you, but
You know
I'll echo what dream unsaid it's kind of. How do you respond?
And what do you you know, how hard do you work to try to get back to the stage?
You know soak up this feeling because obviously we celebrated with a champagne we've had no rings
But this is the more motivating feeling
How do you respond how do you turn the page to?
New challenges ahead. So
will be I
Mark Janey and then Howard last three
stiff mark Schwartz ESPN first, can you explain how you felt watching clay go down and
Secondly, how much did you have left at the end when you had that look to possibly put your team ahead and go on to?
Game seven
It's just tough in terms of a
Guy like clay that left it all out there. He put his playing amazing tonight
There to see a freak play like that where you know, he lands awkwardly. I don't know the diagnosis yet, but
You think about the person and the guy and how much he loves to play the game and
That's the only thoughts you have. It's really not about you know
What it means in terms of playing basketball, it's just I'm more concerned about him as an individual and and hoping that he's alright
so I
Can you know
Leave it at that but the shot was
when I take ten out of ten times and
You know, we ran a play that was kind of
we got a decent look off of you know, kind of a bobble catch and I you know, I was
Conceited rim, so I shot it
I'll live with it
we always talked about that, you know myself and clay in terms of shots that we take you live with it and
You know, I'd shoot that shot every every day of the week
Jani back Center Steph Janie McCauley from Associated Press
You've said so many times this season
You know how difficult it is to win it all and how you guys need to cherish every moment together while this team is together
To do the events of the last couple days where it where Kevin has surgery and clay goes down. Just just show you how
Many things have to go right
For a special a championship. I mean and how things sometimes don't don't work out for sure
I mean the history of this NBA you could I like
every team that was supposed to win or had the best team and all the different storylines and
you know 82 games and a full playoff run a lot can happen and just
No matter how much you fight and just leave it all out there on the floor. I
Think the way that we have talked and
Described this this journey and whatnot. I don't a there's ever been a situation where we've taken anything for granted and
That's something I can look back and just help hold up we all can hold our head high that uh
you know, we gave it everything we got to your point about, you know, two guys who
Go down and the game's kind of taken away from them in those moments
It's it's not a good feeling at all. And it's kind of a helpless feeling in terms of
You know two free plays that
you know send these guys back to the to the locker room, so
It's tough, but it's part of the basketball is part of the game
Again, I just you know, hope their recoveries are strong and they come back, you know better than they were before
Howard last question here in the left side Howard back from Bleacher Report's Steph when you think about the toll of five-year run
Can take all the extra games you think about some key free agencies. The injuries sean has talked about possibly retiring
Does this feel like if not necessarily the end then kind of a major transition point for who you guys have been you expect
serious change potentially coming forward I
mean, I'm not sure there's a lot of obviously decisions that will go into the summer and we'll deal with those accordingly, but
You know
I think true champions like we are we should be able to adapt and keep the same kind of DNA no matter
what our roster looks like next year and
I
Have high hopes about you know being back on the stage
Whether it looks the same or not, or obviously we're changing buildings and all that type of stuff
you know, there's gonna be some change but
We'll enjoy this summer. Like you said, it's been a long journey. We've played a lot of basketball
Get away from the game a little bit refresh the minds guys go through some rehabs and get get back stronger
Your next season will be next season and will come back with the right mentality so
It's kind of hard to talk about because it's a tough way to go out and stuff to lose in the finals but
Story's not over yet
Thank you stuff